somebody who's sitting to my right right
now and to his right is his belt as
being the reigning lightweight
heavyweight champion of the UFC Daniel
Cormier good to see you Dan you good to
see you too thank you very so that belt
does that belt travel with you or it
just travels where it just shows up
wherever you go sometimes it just shows
up but like I do travel with one okay I
Drive a Prius and in my Prius in the
front seat is one of my belts
I take pictures driving my Prius not
kind of thirty minutes away so that
saved the gas all right I save some gas
I Drive my Prius on my bill so now would
you wear that let's say you you go let's
say Game three I assume because you're
Saints fan your big yellow ones pelicans
famine no no rockets I love the Rockets
okay so alright so Pat this would be
great Patrick Regis showed up to the
Rockets game in his green jacket
we don't wear your UFC belt to the
Rockets if they told me to write so I
live up in the Bay Area they play the
Warriors in the Conference Finals as
anticipated and they say DC bring the
belt I'm wearing the belt and I'm
wearing the belt to rule on the other
team with my rocket Jersey yeah I get a
lot of so I get a lot of flack for that
up in the Bay Area because I root for
the Rockies but you know what like the
Rockets and yeah I would definitely wear
my belt so what where did the Rockets
love come from again your fro yeah okay
so you're the from Lafayette Louisiana
so it's like three and a half hours from
Houston and when I was growing up there
were no pelicans right there were the
Hornets that already left right so you
either like the Hawks are you like the
Rockets it was like the two closest
teams and there's also the Astros are
the Braves you know you had to choose
from Houston or Atlanta and I liked just
like the Braves in baseball because they
were better and I liked the Rockets
because I just like a team Olajuwon so
yeah I mean Marshall Faulk was from the
Bayou I always became a Braves fan
because of the superstation yeah please
do the south so right we watch them
Daniel Cormier here on the Rich Eisen
show also part of the Ultimate Fighter
undefeated the 27th season of the
longest-running reality sports program
on television debuts tomorrow night at
10:00 p.m. Eastern on on fs1
let's talk about your fighting career
right now your next fight is against ste
paimio church right yeah
everybody believes that that is just a
stepping stone potentially for you to
get to Brock Lesnar is that is that a
straight line for you to you know man I
think that's what Stevie and I are both
you know Brock such a big fight right he
brings a lot of new eyes the WWE eyes
follow him and he's one of those guys
that just has this massive appeal when
he steps into the Octagon people watch
and we're fighting for the Heavyweight
Championship so winning that belt and
becoming the to division champion is the
most important thing to me but man to
fight Brock Lesnar would be unbelievable
I've been involved in some big fights
you know with the John Jones fights in
the Anderson Silva fight UFC 200 now
fighting for two belts and then as I had
stated in my career to fight a guy like
Brock Lesnar would be amazing well
what's it like to to fight somebody you
lose to somebody hmm that's somebody
then pops yeah for a steroid yeah and
then it's ruled no contest
it's crazy what's it like it's crazy
because you were there right I lost a
fight you know think people could tell
me whatever this this any other you know
you didn't get a fair shake I'm a
competitor I lost the fight so when I
went into my last fight as the champion
I said you know I'm fighting for a
vacant belt because he disqualified
himself again by doing by getting tested
positive steroids but I don't feel like
the champion until I win a fight to earn
the belt back you don't think you lost
it because you're going against somebody
who tilted the playing field yeah I mean
you can look at it that way but I lost
the fight you know I mean and I should
have been better I should have been good
enough to beat him regardless of the
circumstances and I wasn't anyone to
fight so I went fought a new guy now for
vacant belton one again so non the champ
I got that you got the belt right there
stepping up in weight class right now to
take on me Oh judge how difficult is
that it's gonna be tough he's a big guy
he's the most successful heavyweight
champion we've ever had but I like to
chase dreams you know ever from when I
was a kid to the Olympics I've always
dreamed real big and I feel like if I
could do become the light heavyweight
and a heavyweight champ at the same time
this has never been done Conor McGregor
is the only person that's ever held two
title simultaneously but it was 145 in
155 nobody's done it against us 6-4
245-pound man like steep a meal just I'm
excited about it so how much weight do
you have to gain I'm not gonna gain
weight to 265 I'm gonna probably fight
around to 28 to 29 so I'm gonna be about
15 20 pounds lighter than him but it's
okay early in my career I fought a
heavyweight
I fought one heavyweight fight at 224 so
just a matter of me being fast in shape
and ready to go Daniel Cormier here on
the Rich Eisen show you mentioned
McGregor on behalf of the Rich Eisen
show here we appreciate you not throwing
a trash can through the window of the
bus that we sent for you to come here it
was crazy
thank you for that Daniel it was crazy
it was good you would dig Rich Dad
what's one the way from Ireland right
somebody would go hey Conor like I don't
know if this is the best idea
they went five and a half hours they
flew five and a half hours from Dublin
to New York City and him and his boys
were on that private plane and they were
going and they were like you know what
we see could be even this team we're
gonna get him and then when they got to
the arena and kind of grabbed the the
dolly they nobody like nobody ever goes
hey maybe we should approach this in a
different way you know
but that that's Conor right he's so big
not only in that action but just in his
fight career in general so I guess it's
kind of what you come to expect so who's
your training partner right now Cain
Velasquez okay no former UFC heavyweight
champion two-time champ
I still believe he's the greatest
heavyweight champion of all time and
I've got some other guys that I'm
bringing in any connection to hubby
hubby we'll be in the gym but he's uh
he's too small he can't really train I
know the only reason why I'm bringing
this up is I'm trying to see you know
your your take on McGregor yeah with
going against my teammate I believe yeah
pretty much so okay I just want to put
it all on the table right here yeah do
you think any of that was staged
no no nothing associ he didn't have to
didn't didn't kind of get credentialed
to have to get it all so Conor has okay
he had a ticket no he's the biggest star
right
not only in MMA in like in sport he's
one of the big stars in sport correct he
has his own group of photographers is
called the Mac life the McGregor life
they are credentialed to go to UFC
events right one of the guys that works
for the Mac Life open the door and let
him in to the arena so one of the guys
that he employs was there to film it and
he opened the door and then Connor and
the boys got got into the arena so do
you think he regrets this no I think he
does he's put out some tweets on
Instagram he said you know if you don't
learn from lessons then you're not smart
you know it's only a lesson every day is
a chance to learn so I think he regrets
it a little bit you know I think he
regrets the action he's a very smart man
it's crazy because normally everything
would it was calculated right he does
things to get to the next thing and I
think on this one he's kind of dealt
with emotion for the first time in
dealing with emotion at times can get
you kind of in trouble so can somebody
talk you down I mean I've seen some of
your yeah where John Jones press
conference day once it's a go it's a go
but it was in the moment we didn't have
five and a half hours on the private
plane from Dublin just go to Brooklyn
doesn't it seem like like a guy again I
always think of a Guy Ritchie movie with
him that he gets on a plane and the
cameras and fro justify that they're
saying the cameras in front of him and
he's staring directly in the camera
wordlessly doesn't even read a book for
five and a half hours on the flight not
reading the book Lutton listen I'm not
watching a DVD he's just staring
thinking about what he's gonna do once
he gets to Brooklyn I just didn't you
know honestly man the visual right like
um he this is gonna cost him he's gonna
have to pay these guys that were injured
on the bus but um that visual of him
leaving the courthouse and the handcuffs
and stuff man that's gonna play in
people's minds forever you know it's
like I don't know how even though he's a
genius I don't know how he's gonna spin
this one that's one that I'm wondering
how's he gonna spin it I wonder if he's
gonna say something like I was I I came
out of the courthouse like an old-school
gangster in Brooklyn like you know Al
Capone or something you know you know
you don't know because he has a way of
spinning things and I'm just kind of
interested to see how he's gonna try to
spin this deal you don't think he's
gonna spin it into a fight against Kobe
well he's gonna fight cabina and
everybody's gonna be Baja everyone's
gonna be
well if he did that with his boss then
maybe Willis we got a tune in to see
what's going on it's gonna be a massive
fight but I'm saying like how do you
spend that bad visual into something to
help you build a fight
if anybody can try to do that it'll be
McGregor I bet a couple more minutes
here with Daniel Cormier so what's your
endgame here what do you see if with for
your cold are you I'm 39 man I'm out by
next year like by time I turn 40 March
20th 2019 I'm out so you don't have any
breezin yeah no laughs you be the Saints
he's found the fall in the youth and I
hope we can keep hoping and keep it
going forever anyway pads in at home oh
he's the best the best way he stands
behind there and he's looking over the
line I just loved it the way his neck is
so craned up trying to look over to
offensive lineman to throw it on the
field I'm like man is you got to think
like he's that short and he done he
can't see the guys right is there any
way he sees these guys you know so I was
like they're on instinct there are times
where maybe he's blocked out yeah but he
is so incredibly accurate he's prepared
and knowledgeable that he just he he out
does it all rich I don't worst ballot
material oh yeah but you don't believe
you can continue fighting before I could
but I don't need to I care about like my
legacy and everything a lot of your guys
if Muhammad Ali went out on his back it
can happen to any of us in fighting
because that's what happens right your
heroes they go out on their back and
fighting and in combat sports I don't
want to be one of those guys I want to
be one of those guys that goes off and
does my thing and leaves my legacy
intact
I've main evented and been at the top of
the car at my entire UFC career
I don't want end up fighting on like the
prelims are in the opener of the
pay-per-view I want to stay in these
spots that I've been where it builds to
that madness of the main event the
energy is insane if you've ever been a
UFC men the energy of a big fight when I
fight Jones or Anderson by time we get
in that cage it feels like the roof is
gonna fly off the t-mobile arena or the
Honda Center because people are just so
wrong
up and I I don't want to be fighting
early in the night not really
experiencing that anymore I care about
my legacy so you're saying you get to
Lesnar that's it I get to Lesnar I get
this title with ste pain and I get to
Lesnar or Jones when he comes back you'd
fight him again
oh yeah it's fight him again you don't
think that he you may never see people
he may never give me a fair shake but I
want to try to get it done means a lot
to me to win that fight what would it
mean completion right because he's the
only guy that's beating me nobody else
is beating me he I've lost two fights in
my career and they're both into him
everybody else I smashed he's the only
guy that's shown inability to compete
with me in the Octagon so for me I need
to try to write that and you wouldn't be
concerned at all that you would be
stepping in that octagon on unequal
footing
he'll pride sheet again because that's
what he's done every time every time we
fought he's uh he's tested positive for
something but at the end of the demo
competitor I like to fight alright
before I let you go tell me about the
Ultimate Fighter premiering tomorrow
night 10:00 p.m. Eastern on FS 1 tell me
it's awesome it's a great show
longest-running my sport reality showing
em in TV all undefeated fighters rich
every person on that show is undefeated
the fights are great the coaching staffs
mine and Steve Bay's are great just
gonna be a really good season it's about
the kids didn't have Stevie and I
running at each other fighting arguing
we took a back seat and played a part in
these young men's journeys and it's it's
a real fun season and again tickets for
UFC 226 go on sale next week for July
7th in Las Vegas Nevada
move your fun stuff yep hey Daniel
thanks for coming on don't be a stranger
there's a first of hopefully many times
yes please what do you think what do you
want the Saints to do next week what
would you you know I mean I'm a bit I'm
a big dreamer you know I'm just kind of
hoping that they get Sam Donald you know
my dream big rich why why not shoot for
the stars if you're gonna shoot they
might have to go with the Ditka draft
they'd have to give up all their dress
all the way up there yeah hey thanks for
coming in thanks for bringing the
hardware yeah greatly appreciate that
thank you Daniel Cormier here on
Chai's and show for the TV audience one
more segment with with daniel elgin
baylor coming up shortly here on the
show we want your haikus your sports
haikus I'm loathe to say what the rules
are
Mike they'll - for what are the rules
for a haiku what are the rules for a 5 7
5 I believe you have already submitted a
haiku that may not follow that look at
that look right there
look at his work he's checking his work
and shaking his head and staring it down
you know to count syllables right ok 5 7
5 Brian Urlacher still to come in the
middle of our number oops - oops need 6
more syllables of oops is in the second
line of your haiku I thought it was
words they leave it leave it
just don't touch it don't touch it
actually when we come back we'll hear
your your misfired haiku to set the
stage a 4/4 - oh for rich number 2 Dolph
thanks for coming Daniel thank you the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience